hey guys welcome to our awesome home gym
awesome not that great
[Applause]
yeah okay maybe it's not that great it's
messy
the walls are dirty there's no place for
the weights
the mirrors just does not work well
honestly
most of it just looks bad so
my best friend donnie my brother clifton
they're not too happy with the gym so i
think it's time
for transformation yeah yeah yeah
let's do it amazing home gym
transformation let's get it
[Music]
but mistakes make you strong
all right so step one of the home gym
transformation is
get everything out right yeah let's do
[Music]
it
all right everything is out so step two
we gotta clean it
[Music]
all right guys step three paint let's go
[Music]
so
[Music]
step four romance let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys it looks great so far
right oh yeah the walls are painted the
floor mats are in
yeah hey guys what's new
well it's a little bit empty we need
something
immersed let's get some mirrors in good
idea step
five let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
step number six a huge fan
why because it's gonna get super hot in
here when you workout
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
32 inch as well it's perfect for the gym
yeah and for youtube
yeah but while we do heat cardio and
spinning
but yeah this is it step number seven
smart tv
let's get it on the wall
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stay pink blackboard
[Music]
step number nine a barbell rack you need
a gym to be clean and tidy and you can't
let your barbells
just lie on the floor
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
step 10 the storage rack
[Music]
all right guys we're here the last step
we're gonna put all the gym equipment
in this place let's do it
body solid gym machine the squat rack
the treadmill
[Music]
benches
[Music]
just a few extra things here and there
[Music]
they're great for all the extra
equipment
[Music]
guys the gym is finally ready so now we
can finally start to work out and
now i'm ready to create more fitness
videos for you guys
and remember to check out my brother's
new youtube channel
where he'll show you how to paint the
wall install the mirrors
the tv and the fan everything step by
step
alright guys we'll see you in the next
video cheers